Власна абсолютна більшість у парламенті?
Про це попередні українські президенти могли тільки мріяти.
А от Володимиру Зеленському - вдалось.
Але добре це чи погано для української держави?
І які шанси та ризики несе в собі "зелена" парламентська більшість?
Якщо ви оптиміст, то монобільшість у парламенті дає шанс
на швидкі та рішучі реформи, які попередня влада
анонсувала, але так і не провела.
Володимир Зеленський обіцяв побороти корупцію,
очистити суди, провести податкову та інші реформи.
Хоча за українською Конституцією президент
не має повноважень виконати свої обіцянки,
парламентська більшість таки дасть молодому главі держави змогу
не лише представляти Україну за кордоном
та віддавати накази військовим, але й впливати
на всі без винятку сфери життя країни.
Якщо ж ви песиміст, то одразу згадаєте, що
демократична влада - це баланс важелів і противаг.
Проте з настільки великою народною любов’ю до Зеленського -
а йдеться про розгромну перемогу "Слуги народу" усюди,
крім Львівщини та Донеччини - нова партія влади
може взагалі не зважати на думку опозиції у парламенті.
Єдині рішення, які молодому президенту не вдасться
аж так зовсім легко провести через Верховну Раду - це зміни до Конституції.
Тим більше, що результати виборів показали:
інші політсили поки неготові конкурувати з "зеленими".
Востаннє під куполом Верховної Ради
монобільшість існувала ще за Радянського Союзу.
У Зеленського назбирується іще більше мандатів,
ніж колись мали комуністи - аж 254.
Але від молодої та рішучої влади політичні оглядачі
очікують не лише швидкого запуску реформ
і боротьби з корупціонерами, але й неминучих
хаотичних рішень, помилок і призначень випадкових людей.
Чи буде президентська фракція зважати на критику
опонентів та коригувати свої дії - велике питання.
Водночас монобільшість у парламенті не означає монолітності.
Нові народні депутати – а вибори 2019-го оновили
склад Верховної Ради на понад 80 відсотків –
переважно не знайомі між собою, не мають
спільних поглядів й об’єднані лише авторитетом Володимира Зеленського.
З часом всередині такої великої фракції виникнуть сірі кардинали,
групи прихильності до окремих олігархів тощо.
І Зеленському доведеться вирішувати проблему партійної
дисципліни та різношерстності власної фракції.
Формально Україна має парламентсько-президентську форму правління.
Але результати голосування і за нового главу держави,
і за нову Верховну Раду показали:  поки що українці
тяжіють до зовсім протилежного - до президентської форми.
Всі свої надії вони пов’язують з однією-єдиною людиною,
а якщо цій людині не вдасться виконати обіцяне -
то в майбутньому саме з нею виборці пов’яжуть і всі свої розчарування.